[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد كشفت وثائق حصلت عليها
قناه ايران انترناشونال النظام الايراني
يحاول اخفاء مساله تحصيل ديونه من العراق
وان المصرف العراقي للتجاره يرفض حتى الان
مطالب طهران بما في ذلك تحويل اجزاء من
اموال ايران المجمده الى الخارج ايران
انترناشونال تقول ان الوثائق كشفت بان
حكومه رئيس دابت على تقديم معلومات غير
صحيحه حول تحصيل ديونها من العراق خلال
العامين الماضيين وان وسائل الاعلام
الايرانيه نقلت مزاعم المسؤولين في النظام
الذين قالوا انه تم سداد طلبات الغاز
الايرانيه من العراق على اساس شهري وبشكل
روتيني وانه ليس لدى طهران اي ديون من
العراق الى جانب نقليه تصريحات وزير
النظام او النفط عفوا الايراني جواد اوجي
الذي اكد فيها بان طهران تمكنت العمل
الماضي وهذا العام من الحصول على جميع
المتاخرات المتعلقه بص الغاز الى العراق
واضافت ايران ينترشونال انا مسؤوليه نظام
الايراني على طويله المفاوضات في بغداد
تبنوا سياسه التسول لدرجه ان طهران لا
تستطيع حتى دفع 32 مليون يورو لست وستين
الف طن من الشعير كانت قد اشترتها في وقت
سابق بسبب عدم سداد بغداد للمبلغ المطلوب
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من بغداد
داوود عبد زايد رئيس مجلس الاعمال الوطني
العراقي اهلا بك ومن عمان مهدي جاسم
الباحث في شان العراقي اهلا بكم ضيوفي
اسمحولي ان ابدا من عمان معك سيد جاسم في
الواقع انصدقت تقارير ايران انترناشونال
نحن اذا امام روايه احد طرفيها يراوغ او
لا يصدق القول حضرتك هل تعتقد بان ايران
تراوغ وبانها فعلا لم تتسلم
اموالها من العراق او ان العراق يراوغ
وانه بطلب الخزانه الامريكيه فعليا اوقف
تزويد ايران بالاموال
شكرا جزيلا لحضرتك الكريم من بغداد يعني
سياسه المناورات التي يتم اتخاذها
واتباعها من قبل النظام الايراني للتملص
والخلاص من العقوبات التي زادت من خسائره
التي وصلت الى ربما اكثر من 400 مليار
دولار سياسه الضغط التي تنتهجها ايران على
الحكومه العراقيه وخاصه حكومه السوداني
بين من خلال الاحراج الذي يتم ممارسه في
عمليه كشف ما يتم تناقله من انباء ايرانيه
وتصريحات على مستوى رؤساء وبالتالي على
الحكومه العراقيه ان تجيب حقيقه هل انها
خلقت التعهدات التي اعطتها تجاه العقوبات
والمجتمع الدولي بانها لا تستطيع او ربما
ايضا اخفت عمليه او طريقه تسرب هذه
الاموال الى ايران هذه المناوره في الضغط
على السياسه العراقيه وعلى اتفاقيات
العراقيه وخاصه
ذهب الى واشنطن من حضرتك لو سمحت لي قبل
الانتقال الى بغداد حضرتك لما تقول بان
ايران تحرج الجانب العراقي ونحن نتحدث عن
حليفين
متشاركين في العديد من المجالات تحرجها
لايه اسباب لماذا
بكل تاكيد هناك فاء رئيسي في النظام
السياسي العراقي وهو الاحزاب المتنفذه
وربما ايضا المرتبطه عقائديا مع ايران
لديها القدره على الضغط على النظام
السياسي العراقي وهناك ايضا التزام حكومي
معلوم ومعروف وتعهدات رسميه امام المجتمع
الدولي وامام بالتحديد امام واشنطن في
عمليه مراقبه مسار الدور الدولار العراقي
وهنا الجميع يعلم ان هناك جهات فرضت عليها
عقوبات داخل النظام السياسي العراقي لديها
مصارف لديها نفوذ لديها تعاملات ماليه
وبالتالي تستطيع هذه الجهات من ان تتعامل
مع
تهريب او تحويل الاموال خارج العراق وهنا
تستطيع الحكومه الايرانيه ان تحرج النظام
السياسي العراقي بهذا التصريح وبالتالي
وضعته
ان يخرج الحقيقه
ما الذي يحدث في هذه العلاقه الثنائيه
الايرانيه العراقيه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم احييك واحيي ضيفك
الكريم وحي المشاهدين الكرام
بصراحه يعني المعلومات الرسميه وشبه
الرسميه انه المبالغ اللي مترتبه على
العراق من خلال تصدير الغاز الايراني
لمحطات الكهرباء العراقيه لحد الان لمده
عامين لم تسدد الحكومه العراقيه المبالغ
اعتقد اخر لقاء للسيد رئيس الوزراء مع
قناه العربيه
كان المبلغ يتجاوز العشره مليار يورو
وباجراءات الصرف يتطلب لها موافقات معينه
من البنك المركزي العراقي ومن البنوك
المراسله التي تمتلك الارصده اللي هو مصرف
العراقي للتجاره اللي هي سيتي
والى اخره من البنوك عالميه تتطلب اجراءات
وموافقات من خلال الاطلاق المجزء وفق
برامج مثل ما كانت الح كومات السابقه من
عام 2015 لحد
كانت تطلق مبالغ الغاز
للجمهوريه الايرانيه من خلال بروسيجر معين
يتفق عليه
التي قلت سيد داوود العراق تخلفت عن
ساداتهم ما علاقه هذا الملف وبسط لنا
المعلومه ولمشاهدينا بملف ما نقلته ايران
انترناشونال بمنع او توقيف بغداد لتسديد
اموال ايرانيه
منع لتجديد اموال ايرانيه لبغداد تمنع
تسديدها او من الاموال الايرانيه بالضبط
ايران انترناشونال تقول ايران انترناشونال
تقول بانه بغداد منعت او اوقفت على ايران
تسديد اموال تخص مجالات عديده دون موافقه
الخزانه الامريكيه بينما ايران تقول بان
هذه الاموال تردن بطريقه دوريه وروتينيه
وهنا حصل لخطف في الواقع
بصراحه الحكومه العراقيه
رصدت الاموال للحكومه الايرانيه من خلال
الحساب المفتوح بمصرف التي بي اي العراقي
بكامل استحقاقات الحكومه الايرانيه ولكن
المصرف العراقي للتجاره ارض سته هي كلها
خارجيه وليس داخليه ببنوك مراسله العمله
اللي تم رصدها
لاستحقاقات الكهرباء هي باليورو وليس
بالدينار ولكن اجراءات
العقوبات على ايران يتطلب من خلال اعمال
الاطلاق هذه المبالغ معين بين المصرف
العراقي من بنك المركز العراقي والبنوك
المراسله على شكل دفعات
وباسباب ومسببات معينه حسب الاتفاق اللي
مبرم بين العراق وايران سيد جاسم بشكل
معلومات الحق المعلومات الرسميه والشبه
الرسميه انه لمده عامين لم تطلق لحد الان
بشكل اعم وكانه هناك شيء جديد يحدث في هذه
العلاقه ثنائيه يعني بين الفتره والاخرى
بدات تتسرب معلومات مره عن مشكله المياه
هذه المره عن النفقات كل مره هناك تسريب
لبعض المعلومات ينبئ بانه هناك شكل جديد
من العلاقه بين ايران والعراق هل تقرا ذلك
حضرتك
سؤال لو سمحتي شكرا عفوا عفوا عفوا
تبقى مسارات السياسه الامريكيه ثابته تجاه
القضايا الخارجيه او علاقه الواشنطن
بايران ومنها ايضا ابعاد التاثير الايراني
على النظام السياسي والنظام الاقتصادي
وحتى
النافذه الماليه الوحيده ربما لايران
بانتعاش اقتصادها او الحيلوله
بالتهرب من هذه العقوبات هذه السياسه
الثابته يجب ان تخضع الجميع ومنها ايضا
السياسه
العراقيه التي الان تمر بمخاضات كبيره
منها المخاض الاقتصادي وصعود الدولار
ونزول الدولار وايضا يعني موضوع
القصف الايراني والتركي المستمر وهذه ازمه
كبيره ايضا السدود والمياه هذه ازمه ايضا
اقليميه خارجيه بالتالي كل هذه المسارات
التي تتحدث عنها اليوم السياسه الامريكيه
يجب ان تكون من الثوابت لدعم اذا تحدثنا
عن دعم النظام السياسي ودعم حكومه
السوداني للوقوف على اهم
الازمات والمشاكل التي تحاول واشنطن اليوم
من خلال تحركات السفيره الامريكيه والتي
اثارت اللقط كثير بان هذه التحركات ربما
هي خارج نطاق الدبلوماسيه الدوليه لكن
واشنطن تريد ان تقول اننا انني اريد ان
اقدم الدعم للنظام السياسي تاره وايضا ضمن
الشراكه الامريكيه
العراقيه الشامله وبالتالي محاوله الحفاظ
على الاستقرار الاقتصادي العراقي السيد
داوود هل تعتقد بانه نحن داخلون على مرحله
جديده قد تتغير فيها البوصله العراقيه
باتجاه واشنطن بعد ان كانت باتجاه طهران
باختصار ان تكرمت
بصراحه الحكومه العراقيه وضع لا يحسد عليه
الغاز الايراني هو شريان الكهرباء بالعراق
اللي دولار هو العامل الرئيسي بالتغيير
الاقتصادي العراقي من خلال العقوبات في لا
سمح الله من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
والعراق لازم يتعامل مع الدوله الجاره
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه بطريقه تكون
ما تنعكس السياسات هذه على خلق ازمه
سياسيه داخل البلد
انتهى تماما توقيت هذه الحلقه اود شكرا
لكم
على المقاطعه من بغداد داوود عبده زايد
رئيس مجلس الاعمال الوطني العراقي شكرا
جزيلا لك ومن عمان مهدي جاسم الباحث في
الشان العراقي جزيل الشكر لكما السلام
عليكم